windriver was written and directed by
taylor sheridan and stars jeremy renner
as a veteran game hunter in wyoming a
Native American reservation known as
Wind River he's the guy that you call if
something is eating your cattle or some
animal is disturbing the peace and when
he's out trying to do his job he comes
across the dead body of a young Native
American woman barefoot frozen miles
away from any civilization and when
Elizabeth Olson who plays an FBI agent
comes to town to try to solve this
mystery she uses his help to track how
she could have possibly gotten that far
into the wilderness and he uses his
skills as a game hunter to try to track
down the murderer
but this isn't just a murder mystery
it's really a film about a man coming to
terms with his very haunting past as
well as a group of people in this case
Native Americans and how they are so
unfairly treated by the government
there's some text that comes up towards
the end of this film that knocked me
flat I stared at the end credits for
like five straight minutes without
really doing much of anything in fact
the lights came on and before I knew it
the custodian was in the theater
cleaning up the aisles because this film
mesmerized me it's one of my favorites
of the year so far
Sheridan's dialogue is brutal it really
captures the feel of this location it's
very much so about how one place in
which you are forced to live can dictate
how you view the world and can keep you
restricted to not blossoming or doing
really anything else than surviving
there's a great line about survival in
this film but as I said it's very much
so a tribute to what Native Americans
deal with there is a fantastic
performance in this movie by Gil burning
ham who you might remember from hell or
high water another script from Taylor
Sheridan and he plays the father of the
young girl that's found dead it's a
crushing performance it's one that's
filled with so much grief but also a lot
of anger because he's upset about the
way his family's been treated by the
government and by the world a lot of the
people that have to live in Wind River
feel the same way like they're just
controlled they're all squashed into
this one place and they
get out and jeremy renner is also
dealing with a very sad past and he
shares a connection with the people who
live in Winn River and we get a lot of
great scenes between himself and Gil
Birmingham these are two excellent
performers working at the top of their
game in fact this is the best
performance I've ever seen from Jeremy
Renner
he's very understated and this is
probably the first time for myself that
I didn't look and see Jeremy Renner in a
movie I didn't look and say that's
Hawkeye or that's the guy from Hurt
Locker no I mean he disappeared
Elizabeth Olsen's character is the
fish-out-of-water she's not used to this
environment she didn't even bring proper
clothing she would have frozen to death
Jeremy Renner says if they didn't give
her the clothes that they give her so
she's very much so running to catch up
but she's not just like some weak
character in which people are saving her
every two seconds because she can't
figure out what's going on she proves
that during some extremely grisly and
brutal action scenes that were extremely
violent and I could not have been
happier it was very very cool the way
they handled it and they did it in a way
that kind of stopped you cold because
the film is a drama for so long and then
all of a sudden when the body count
starts happening I was like damn shit
just got real and it hits you because
it's not an action movie it looks like
people are dying they did such a great
job capturing the darkness that this
town is experiencing and this is one of
those few movies similar to movies like
7 where the town feels like a character
the location seems like it is part of
this movie that just infects everyone in
it and I won't get into spoilers of
course but the finale is so satisfying
and so tense it's been a while since
I've seen an ending that truly cathartic
I loved Wind River I think it is a film
you should see without a doubt it's also
kind of an important movie surprisingly
which really snuck up on me
I'm gonna give Wind River and a
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]